Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
In the world of digital 3D modeling, it often
occurs that we are looking for surfaces that
are not perfectly smooth, but have some sort
of surface detail.
Wrinkles, engravings, grain on a wooden table
are excellent examples of details that we
can add to our models, and computer graphics
people like to collectively call these things
displacement maps.
Artists often encounter cases where they like
the displacements on one object, but the object
itself is not really interesting.
However, it could be that there is a different
piece of geometry these details would look
great on.
Consider this problem solved, because in this
piece of work, the input is two 3D models:
one with interesting geometric details, and
the other is the model onto which we transfer
these surface details.
The output will be our 3D geometric shape
with two of these models fused together.
The results look absolutely amazing.
I would love to use this right away in several
projects.
The first key part is the usage of metric
learning.
Wait, technical term, so what does this mean
exactly?
Metric learning is a classical technique in
the field of machine learning, where we're
trying to learn distances between things where
distance is mathematically ill-defined.
Let's make it even simpler and go with an
example: for instance, we have a database
of human faces, and we would like to search
for faces that are similar to a given input.
To do this, we specify a few distances by
hand, for instance, we could say that a person
with a beard is a short distance from one
with a moustache, and a larger distance from
one with no facial hair.
If we hand many examples of these distances
to a learning algorithm, it will be able to
find people with similar beards.
And in this work, this metric learning is
used to learn the relationship between objects
with and without these rich surface details.
This helps in the transferring process.
As to creating the new displacements on the
new model, there are several hurdles to overcome.
One, we cannot just grab the displacements
and shove them onto a different model, because
it can potentially look different, have different
curvatures and sizes.
The solution to this would be capturing the
statistical properties of the surface details
and use this information to synthesize new
ones on the target model.
Note that we cannot just perform this texture
synthesis in 2D like we do for images, because
as we project the result to a 3D model, it
introduces severe distortions to the displacement
patterns.
It is a bit like putting a rubber blanket
onto a complicated object.
Different regions of the blanket will be distorted
differently.
Make sure to have a look at the paper where
the authors present quite a few more results
and of course, the intricacies of this technique
are also described in detail.
I hope some public implementations of this
method will appear soon, I would be quite
excited to use this right away, and I am sure
there are many artists who would love to create
these wonderfully detailed models for the
animated films and computer games of the future.
In the meantime, we have a completely overhauled
software and hardware pipeline to create these
videos.
We have written down our joyful and perilous
story of it on Patreon - if you're interested
in looking a bit behind the curtain as to
how these episodes are made, make sure to
have a look, it is available in the video
description.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!